pay on Tick Tock is horrendous let me
explain Tick Tock only pays about two to
four cents per 1000 views so even if you
get a ridiculous amount of views you're
not making much take cabilame for
example he is the most followed tick
tocker on the planet with a whopping 159
million followers and a nearly 18
billion views but in terms of AD revenue
from Tick Tock these 18 billion views
only translates to 540 000 for
perspective if you got the same number
of views on YouTube your total earnings
would be closer to 54 million dollars
assuming a 3 RPM now of course these
tick talkers don't just rely on Tick
Tock ads they also do brand deals and
sponsorships and affiliate marketing and
all that stuff which pose in a whole lot
of money but the disparity between Tick
Tock ads and YouTube ads is still
staggering I mean we're talking about a
100x difference